when penny lee was a student she found a
way to help pay her bills
buying items in australia for family and
friends and sending them back home to
china
but since covet 19 hit business has
dried up
the demand isn't there and also the cost
has been increasing so
it's a really hard business to do this
year
china's overseas shoppers have become
big business in australia
and are known as daigo they buy sought
after australian-made products
including vitamins and baby formula and
resell them in china
connecting with people through messaging
apps like wechat
the high demand has at times stripped
some products from australian shelves
now many stores specifically catering to
the industry
are shut most aigo are chinese students
or tourists and with borders closed
because of the pandemic
the industry has all but disappeared
with some australian brands
seeing a big drop in sales the logistics
are not available and people in china
actually they are decreased the buying
power
they also can find the alternatives in
china
even before the pandemic the industry
was starting to decline
with bigger companies offering similar
services online
and china increasingly regulating goods
entering the country
it's hard to put an exact dollar figure
on the value of [ __ ] sales between
australia and china because of lack of
accurate data but before covert 19
there were tens of thousands of shoppers
operating in australia
and hundreds of stores some experts
believe the
market is worth more than two billion
dollars
relations have recently soured between
australia and china with beijing
increasing tariffs on bali imports and
banning some australian beef products
but some economists don't believe young
shoppers have been influenced by the
rising tensions
the demand from china for australian
goods and services is still going to be
very strong
despite covert and despite some of the
sabre rattling diplomatically that we've
been hearing
in recent months while demand for
products might be strong
it's not clear yet how the lucrative
industry will bounce back in a post
covert 19 world
as australia tries to make its way out
of recession
nicola gage al jazeera sydney